men and women between the ages of 18 and
30 reporting No Sex in the past year and
that has gone up from 10 to 30 percent
for men so over the last decade the
number of men reporting No Sex in the
last year has tripled and the line on
the graph has got where tinder's
introduced and it is exactly where that
inflection for men beginning to go from
the 10 to the 28 according to open
source data a man of average
attractiveness can only be expected to
be liked by slightly less than one
percent of females this equates to one
like for every 115 females and men in
the bottom 10 see just one match per
week at most ultimately most women only
swipe on a handful of men per day while
men are more freewheeling with their
swipes females pass on 95 and like on 5
and men are basically 50 50 left and
right